si l'ordre du jour appelle la question
orale de Madame Catherine de roche à
Madame la Ministre chargée des personnes
âgées et deautonomie c'est la parole ma
cher collègue merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre je souhaite
vous alerter sur les difficultés
financières sérieuses que connaissent
les gestionnaires de logement foyer tant
dans la gestion de leur activité que
dans l'aide à la réhabilitation des
bâtiments alors ce sont des des foyers
logement des logement foyer plus
exactement qui ont été créés dans les
années 70 et dont l'originalité réside
dans leur mode d'accueil de personnes
âgées dans des conditions qui sont
proches du domicile actuellement il
représente 2300 structures en France et
ils accueillent désormais près de 120000
personnes aujourd'hui le parc des
logements foyer a vieilli et les besoins
de rénovation du bâti et des équipements
sont importants tant pour une remise en
état que pour une adaptation encore plus
grande au vieillissement des résidents
afin de prolonger le plus longtemps
possible l'autonomie des personnes ces
logements foyers ont été oubliés de des
politiques nationales pendant de
nombreuses années les financements se
font rares et pourtant les
investissements sont indispensables pour
moderniser ces structures face à des
réglementations extrêmement rigides les
travaux de réhabilitation ne peuvent pas
être imputés à des résidents qui ne
disposent très souvent que de faibles
revenus et les gestionnaires tels que
les CCAS ne souhaitent pas répercuter
des charges trop importantes par le
biais de redevances qui de toute façon
sont encadrés financièrement et donc ils
hésitent aussi devant le coût des
emprunts à contracter d'après les
travaux de l'uncass de l'Union nationale
des centres communaux et intercommunaux
d'action sociale le coût de
réhabilitation pour la rénovation sur
des aspects incontournables des parties
communes d'un Foyet logement est au
minimum compris entre 23000 € à 26000 €
par logement soit 14000 € pour les
travaux dans le logement et 199000 €
pour les parties communes au vu de
l'ensemble de ces éléments je vous
remercie de m'indiquer de de quelles
aides financières de la part des
pouvoirs publics peuvent disposer les
gestionnaires de logement foyer qui sont
en attente de solution pour la
rénovation des bâtiments existants et
l'application aux nouvelles réalisations
merci Maes cher collègue la parole est à
Madame Marie Arlette Carlotti ministre
chargé des personnes handicapées et de
la lutte contre l'exclusion monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice Catherine
de Roch je vous prie de bien vouloir
excuser Michel de l'uné elle préside
actuellement l'assemblée générale des
âgers au ministère comme vous l'avez
très justement souligné existe
aujourd'hui en France 2300
établissements 116000 logements pour des
résidents dont la moyenne d'âge est de
82 ans 80 % de ces lements sont la
propriété de bailleurs sociaux et 56 %
d'entre eux ont plus de 30 ans 65 % des
loyers des foyers logement doivent
aujourd'hui bénéficier de rénovation et
effectivement une étude récente de
l'uncas met en évidence un besoin de
financement de travaux de l'ordre de
360000 € par établissement en moyenne
plusieurs aides donc sont disponibles à
cet effet celles bien sûr qui sont d'ors
et déjà versées par les collectivités
territoriales conseils généraux et
communes celle de la Caisse nationale
d'assurance vieillesse 78 millions
d'euros en prêt sans intérêt qui
représente en gros entre 15 et 20 % des
travaux et qui ont été versés en 2012
ces 78 millions d'euros ont d'ors et
déjà permis de financer 133 projets il
existe aussi des aides de la Caisse des
Dépôts et Consignation mais seulement
pour le public pour le parapubl et et
pour les les structures privées non
lucratives ce sont les prêts phar ou les
écoprêts que vous connaissez enfin un
nouveau prêt vient d'être ouvert 20
milliards mises à disposition des
collectivités territoriales il est
accessible au CCAS qui sont
propriétaires d'environ 20 % des foyers
logement et pour ce cela pour des
travaux supérieurs à 20 à 200 € le mètre
carré et qui devront avoir au moins un
des trois obj objectif suivant
l'amélioration thermique la sécurité et
l'accessibilité parallèlement le
Gouvernement a engagé des réflexion pour
améliorer l'accès et le développement de
ces aides la renégociation de la
convention d'objectif et de gestion
entre l'État et la knnaav sera
l'occasion pour nous pour le
gouvernement de de s'interroger
justement sur une priorité qu'il faudra
donner au foyers logement par ailleurs
subsiste des problématiques inhérentes
aux condition même d'obtention de ces de
ces prêts de la Caisse des dépôts pour
le phare par exemple il faut être 100 %
habilité à l'aide sociale il faut être
aussi titulaire de droits réels donc
propriétaire du mur avec une stratégie
de patrimoine ce qui peut différer
d'ailleurs des priorités du gestionnaire
et pour lescoprés ce sont des conditions
très fortes en terme d'économie
d'énergie qui bien souvent alourdissent
le coût final et sont finalement des
incitatrices alors sauf à faire porter
le surcout comme vous le disiez sur les
résidents et comme vous je partage
l'idée qu'il ne faut pas faire cela
c'est donc vraiment sur l'ensemble de
ces conditions qu'il font désormais agir
alors Michel delunet a lancé des groupes
de travail pour revisiter à la fois la
réglementation et la législation en
matière de foyer logement et pour mieux
définir le modèle économique et la façon
d'accueillir mieux ces publics et cela
va venir renforcer les discussions
qu'elle a d'ors et déjà a entrepris dans
ce sens avec la Caisse des Dépôts merci
madame la sénatrice merci madame de
oui merci madame la ministre de toutes
ces précisions je pense qu'en effet pour
certains le le logement foyer était un
un un mode d'hébergement qui avait
tendance à diminuer mais il reste quand
même très prignant et je pense qu'il
correspond à une une phase de la vie qui
peut être importante pour les
collectivités les collectivités
territoriales d'avoir sur son sur son
territoire ce type de logement mais les
contraintes que vous avez évoqué elles
sont en effet souvent des freins et et
tous les gestionnaires et c'est le cas
dans mon département du Mené Loir disent
que le la la somme reste en charge
Infiné est trop importante et que sans
répercussion sur les redevances il est
impossible pour eux donc je pense que le
travail qui doit être fait sur une une
un assouplissement tout en restant dans
dans des règles de sécurité bien
évidemment et d'accessibilité et majeure
à l'avenir et c'est vrai d'ailleurs dans
d'autres dans d'autres équipements
publics merci mes chers collègues